it's my great pleasure to introduce Paul
who's going to talk
about building extensions with rust I
first met Paul I was working at
Bloomberg but he's now a software
engineer over at Google he's also
maintainer of date you to set up tools
and a core developer so he's taking all
the boxes today so it's great great
pleasure they very much cool someone now
it's better
okay great all right so I
oh ho I almost forgot to start my timer
all right so today I'm going to be
talking about building Python extensions
in rust so this is the result of some
work that I did because I was interested
in maybe writing some rust backends for
date util or other projects that I had
and I sort of went down a rabbit hole
where I ended up contributing
like a huge number of like bindings to
PI o 3 which is kind of how it goes in
open-source but I'm very excited about
the possibility of getting a lot of rust
extensions out there in the community
but you'll see I'm it's not gonna be all
rosy I'm not in the rust evangelism
strike force so I think we're probably
all heard that Python is great glue
language because you can write
high-level api's that are very easy for
people to use
but Python itself it does have a lot of
overhead right it sort of takes some it
takes a lot of the worrying out of the
hands of the programmer but at the cost
of worrying about it itself at runtime
which is why python is great for
orchestration tasks like system
orchestration or for just calling in to
other languages like compiled languages
like C or C++ and in fact a lot of the
great libraries that you know about are
in fact just sort of glue around some
other compiled fast languages right so
numpy or sai pie or matplotlib these are
all calling down into C or C++ or
Fortran but they're giving you that
great powerful API
so just as a quick just to dive into
what it means to write an extension
here's an implementation of the sieve of
eratosthenes which is an algorithm for
finding all the prime numbers less than
or equal to a given number and the way
it works is you just make a list of all
the numbers up to that number and then
you start and then you start with two
and then you cross off all the multiples
of that and then you continue doing that
for all the prime numbers you found
until you've gotten to the end of the
list and then you have a list of all the
prime numbers and you can see this is a
pretty short implementation it's pretty
easy and it works for at least five and
twenty and this is what it looks like if
you write it in the capi it's obviously
much longer but that's not really the
important part what's more important is
that it it involves a lot of details
that python doesn't make you think about
so for example here I'm manually
managing how they like some exception
handling I do that here and here
I'm also manually managing the memory
and I have to manage the reference
counts of all the Python objects that I
create so this is kind of a lot of
complexity and it didn't really all fit
in one slide you can see this is
actually quite a terse way of
programming I have this for loop that's
on one line because on a smaller screen
than this this is all that fits on on
one on one slide if you want readable
text so why would you do anything like
this why would you subject yourself to
it it comes with a lot of performance
benefits so if we compare the Python
version that I wrote to the C version I
wrote the C version is takes 526 minute
microseconds and the Python version
takes 18.6 milliseconds to calculate all
the numbers up to a hundred thousand so
that's like a 35 times speed-up and once
you get past some of the overhead of
just calling the function itself you're
getting into numbers of like 40 or 50
times speed up in the of the hot loop
but it has these downsides that I
mentioned right we'll see you have to
manually manage all your memory you have
to allocate it you have to free it you
have to
all the reference counting otherwise you
get memory leak so you have to keep
track of what returns you a new
reference and then decrement them
correctly and then you can get seg
faults if you decrement them too much
but you can get memory leaks if you
increment them too much and it's not a
memory safe language so if you have an
array in in C you can just it's really
just a pointer to the beginning of the
array and then you just tell it how far
off to go and you have to keep track of
how big the array is and in fact when I
was first implementing this I made this
little mistake which is that to save a
little space and conceptual time I I had
the the sieve start from 2 and go to the
end so the length of that is n minus 1
but you're so used to saying oh I just
either eight from zero to n so I
accidentally said oh I equals zero go to
I less than n but that's longer than the
array and so when this reached the end
it did it wasn't an error it wasn't a
seg fault that just read some random
piece of memory and then turned it into
a Python object and returned it to me
and I was like well that's weird
like 87 is not a prime number Oh David
that's a really bad example but in any
case it's not the next prime number
after five so the this is something that
I wish I was protected from and it is
something I'm protected from in Python
so where can we look next well this is
kind of what rust is all about it's a
systems programming language that is
memory safe this doesn't come up quite
so much in this talk but it's also pays
a lot of attention to concurrency so
it's model really pays attention to me
preventing data races and making you
think about these things a lot but it's
also high performance all this kind of
safety features come at compile time and
not at runtime like they do in Python
and also it's I think an appealing
community for python Easter's because
we're used to this world which is a
great an inclusive community and has
this huge packaged ecosystem where you
can just pip install whatever you want
and in rust they have a similar thing
they have a package manager called cargo
and you can just depend on things and
you cargo build and whatever their
equivalents of things are so
and this is something I think would be
very appealing to people in the Python
community I don't have time to go into
exactly why rust is is a great language
but I just wanted to highlight some
concept just to show you give you a
sense of of the different ways you
approach programming in rust versus
Python so rust cares a lot about
ownership what owns resources so and
this has to do with when they're allowed
to clean up references this is allows
you to avoid having a garbage collector
or reference counting so in general one
thing can like one a variable or name or
can be bound to a resource and can own
that resource and then many things can
have read-only access to it or one other
thing can have write only access to
write access to it but you can't have
multiple things that can write at the
same time so here what we have is we
have something where if you look at this
function it I assign this vector to V it
allocates some resources it binds them
to V and then they're owned by V and so
when V goes out of scope you're allowed
to clean up those resources you don't
have to pay attention to when it gets
freed the compilers doing that for you
it also is going to enforce that these
rules about ownership so here what I'm
doing is I assign V to something then I
pass it to something else which also
wants to take ownership of it and that's
fine so what happens is I assign this
vector to V the vector moves into this
thing that I've also called V and they
take ownership function and then because
it's owned by the V in that take
ownership function when that goes out of
scope at the end of this function the
resources are cleaned up and if you
tried to use them it would be used after
free and in fact that's what I'm doing
here I'm trying to use them and I try
and access this and it's an error but
the compiler is going to catch this it's
going to use its borrow checker and it's
going to say hey you move this here but
then you tried to use it and it's
actually a very informative message I
just explained in words what that is and
I had the comments but I didn't really
need the comments because the compiler
generated all those comments that I
manually annotated it with so you know
some it doesn't always work as cleanly
and nicely as this but generally
speaking the compiler
we'll tell you what it's trying to do
it's quite good about that okay so
that's essentially as much as I'm going
to tell you about rust the rest of this
let's just assume that your perfect
advanced rust programmers so I'm not
gonna explain anything else so you know
this is like the draw a circle and then
draw the rest of the owl all right so
here's my implementation of this in rust
so this part of it is just pure rust it
has nothing to do with Python and in
fact will reuse it later and then this
part is something that just takes that
and translates it into Python so you can
imagine that if this were a function in
the library it would be quite easy to
write Python wrappings for it and this
is using PI o 3 PI o 3 is a library that
provides bindings to the C API in rust
and it uses this this thing is called a
procedural macro and you can just
imagine it's like a decorator and it's
just going to do some transformations on
this to make sure that all the reference
counts happen and all the the types are
are set correctly and what I've done
here is first I've just created this
vector in in rust I've returned it and
then this part says PI list new and
that's going to construct a Python list
and that's the same as in capi creating
like a list and allocating it and doing
all this stuff but the lifetime of this
list is managed by this the lifetime of
this PI object so you can see this has
comparable speed to see so I've written
this function and then I import it and
it does what we expect it to do there's
no 87 and it's also pretty much just as
fast so if we run this in in pure Python
we get 23 milliseconds and in C we get
about seven hundred microseconds and in
rust we get about seven hundred
microseconds so it's it's much tighter
and it's and it's and it's also sort of
memory safe right so how does it work
because see it's binding to C and C
itself is not memory safe so the way it
works is that pi o three operates in two
layers they have the FFI layer which is
a whole bunch of unsafe code and then
they have the safe rust layer so the FFI
layer looks like this where in
this is from the date/time bindings that
I wrote and in the capi there's this
struct called Pied de time C C API and
the right side is what the definition is
in C and then I basically have to copy
this and say give me the exact same
memory layout of that but in rust and
I'm going to say that it's a C function
and has all these C integers and things
like that and so I have all the
functions and then I declare all the
data structures so this is the same data
structure as the as a date/time in in
Python and then I also have all the
little macros and I have to re-implement
all the macros because you can't just
call it like use C preprocessor macros
in rust and then all that gets wrapped
in the safe rust layer and this is the
layer that you would be using if you're
writing if you're writing your rust
extensions so we have this little marker
that says hey all this stuff in here
this is unsafe which sounds like kind of
a cheat where you can just say off do
all this unsafe stuff and but there's
still memory safe but actually this is a
very useful feature in the sense that if
you're trying to audit this code and
you're right running through all this
and you want to find memory safety bugs
the place you're going to look is in all
the brackets that are surrounded by
unsafe and as long as this are sort of
localized you know that you can ignore
80% of the code when you're just looking
for these memory safety bugs so we have
this unsafe stuff which calls the FFI
layer and then it returns something that
has a lifetime that's managed by rust
and has all the the right memory safety
features and that's what you use so then
you would have this thing it's PI date
and then we have some trait that is
called PI date access which gives you
safe rust functions that access all
these things
and so if you want to make a module it's
quite easy you have a function and then
you sort of decorate it with this thing
says PI function and that will construct
it as a function and then when you want
to make a module that's imported all
this PI module thing and this is saying
basically it's good like return it just
initializes this module right so I'll
just add all the functions and then
those are what gets exposed
to the Python so here I have this thing
that's like seconds before it tells you
what the date was some number of seconds
before and I can pass it this integer
and it gives me the right answer but
you'll notice here I've declared this I
64 which is a rust type it's not like
Python integer 64 or anything right but
here I passed it a Python object which
is an integer because PI oh three is
doing all the right things to convert
one to the other behind the scenes in
these procedural macros so it makes it
quite convenient for the end user to not
have to think about this and you can
even do things like manage the
exceptions so you'll notice I don't have
anything about checking for nulls or
anything like that I just return this pi
result and that's what's returned from
the constructor because the constructor
can raise errors and if I get something
that would raise an error here instead
of panicking or seg faulting or anything
like that it just returns error result
and then that percolates out to Python
and raises the correct error you can
also make classes rust is a different
model of inheritance
what doesn't have inheritance it
separates out the data in your classes
from the implementation so we do a
similar thing where we have the data
portion and we declare that a PI class
and then in the implementation we call
these Python methods and so this is the
new for this point and then this is some
function I'm going to call norm so point
is just x and y and we want to know what
the what the norm of that vector is we
add it to our module and then I can
import it just fine and it it works I
can I can create it and I can calculate
that the norm of something three and
four is is five so perfect like you can
create classes you can create modules so
that's the C API approach there's
another approach which is to create FFI
bindings so here's another way that you
can do something similar which is I use
the exact same rust implementation but
now instead of wrapping and in something
that creates Python objects and things
like that I create this CF Fi which is
to say that we'll call the outputs of C
compilers and stuff the lingua franca of
what all languages are going to speak
and we'll
just generate something that's
compatible with that and so this is like
some super unsafe thing it's an external
see unsafe function and its public it's
like oh no don't ever write this and
then it's like oh check out this mutable
pointer right that's very scary and then
this this is very this is even worse
right we're what I've done is I have
this vector and so I convert it to a
mutable pointer so I just have the data
that it represents and then I say mm
forget which means rust please stop
managing this memory like you've
allocated it and stuff now I'm gonna
hand it to someone else to allocate it
to manage this memory so it's fairly
scary but the big advantage of this is
that when I hand this off I can hand it
off to Python I can hand it off to Ruby
I can hand it off to JavaScript I can
hand it off to whatever because all
those languages also speak C but I also
have to hand it this thing D allocate
vector right because I'm the only one
who knows how to allocate and deallocate
vectors because I'm rust and and but I'm
handing it memory that needs to be
de-allocated eventually so I have to end
up passing at this function and then
also another function to let it handle
the memory then we pass it on to what's
called milk snake milk snake is a
library that came out of sentry and what
it is is it's for writing Python
bindings for CF Fi and this goes the
other way right anything that has a CF
if I output milk snake combined too and
it will under the hood it also uses the
library CF fi which is the more
bare-bones version of this so how this
works is now I say R I have to allocate
some of these C types and I allocate
them in Python and then I pull out this
array of like these the C array of C
types and I get and I get out just some
contiguous memory thing and now I have
to convert all that stuff into Python
objects and so I do that by by just
using this list comprehension and now
when s done I've copied all the memory
and I call that D allocate vac and I do
it in this try finally so that even if
this fails I don't leak the memory and
then I return the the list and we're
done interacting with rust so this you
know this is fairly compacted it's it's
not so bad and it
come with some advantages and it also
brings a lot of the same speed so if you
if you look we've got if I run this in C
I get about eight hundred microseconds
if I run it in rust it's like seven
hundred microseconds but let's do this
is very variable I wouldn't say that
rust is like faster than C because of
this and for milk snake I'm getting
something of 1.2 milliseconds so it's
like a little bit more overhead
in this particular example that's not
always going to be the case but
essentially these are all comparable in
speed and it's really about convenience
so when we're looking at this so far you
know I've just been saying oh like
here's all the different ways we can do
this but the one question is like should
we even do this like is there maybe a
better way to do this probably the best
contender for that would be scythe on
scythe on is super convenient when
you're writing wrappers for C or C++ or
you're just trying to get a little bit
of a speed boost you write it
essentially like it's Python and then
behind the scenes this all gets compiled
down to C and even if you you're not
doing anything fancy like using C++ and
and the vector type and stuff you still
get actually a decent speed up and so
here with this simple implementation
that doesn't bring in any rust or any
instability or different package
managers I actually get still I go from
like 23 milliseconds to 3 milliseconds
so it's almost 10 times speed up just
with this fairly simple implementation
compared to C which is maybe about three
times faster but maybe you need three
times faster maybe you don't need it
three times faster so what should you
choose of the things we've talked about
unfortunately I don't think there is
like an answer I can't just be like yes
piyo 3 or never use any of these they're
all terrible what I could say is I can
just give you some trade-offs so in
terms of speed looking at this chart I
would call all of these roughly
comparable if you're looking for like
really good speed probably milk snake
piyo 3 and C are going to be well
they're faster than the scythe on that I
write so I have these these caveats
right one of one is that I didn't pick
some function
it's like a representative task for
everything that you would generally do
as a programmer I picked something that
was going to demonstrate how you have to
deallocate vectors in when you use the
FFI thing so you know that's not exactly
a representative task if you're doing
something that doesn't involve that
these these numbers could be very
different the other thing is I spent
some time optimizing these but I'm not a
super expert siphon optimizer because
most of the time if I need like a little
bit of speed just using sites on it's
kind of enough right so they can take
that with a grain of salt I would
definitely say all of these will give
you some speed boost I have found that
writing that the rust stuff is a little
bit I've the stuff that I just naively
turn out turns out a little bit faster
than the scythe on stuff that I've
written but if you do decide to use rust
should you use this FFI or the API well
the pros and cons here are if you're
using FFI you get that portable
interface we talked about it also has a
smaller rust dependency piyo three
brings in all these bindings and stuff
to the capi with with the FFI your you
have almost no dependency it's basically
just whatever rust you write
it can also be faster like with pi pi
and for certain types of interface
because pi PI can I don't know the
details of this but they're there just
in time compiler will it can make better
optimizations when it's using CF Fi then
when it's binding to the C API because
it has this interaction layer in between
the downsides are this brings in a
runtime dependency on milk snake and CFO
Phi which you may not like there's no
support for Python specific types so for
me if I wanted to use date times like I
have to write all this stuff that like
creates a day time in Python out of some
C memory so if you're just returning
lists of integers and stuff not a big
deal you as you saw I had to do the
memory management in Python and I also
had to write a lot of unsafe rust
directly in my in my functions which I
didn't really have to do in PI in PI o 3
for the API it's basically all safe rust
it doesn't have any runtime dependencies
and you're working directly with Python
objects and then it has some other nice
things because it knows that it's doing
Python for you but the downside is like
I've seen this I've had to change these
slides several times because the API is
fairly unstable I think it still
requires nightly rust
which I haven't found to be a big burden
but some people can't use nightly rest
or don't want to and there are also
certain places where they just haven't
really thought too much about optimizing
the speed so I think a lot of these a
lot of these cons will hopefully go away
in the future but what I would say now
is if you want something that's going to
be in production like tomorrow I'm not
sure that I would choose either of these
rust options maybe I would choose FF I
especially if you're using pi PI but you
know if you're if you're willing to deal
with these kinds of things and try and
help the ecosystem it may not be a bad
idea to invest in in the API it's also
another thing you have to think about is
the task that you're trying to do if
you're just trying to write a wrapper
for some library that's already written
in rust the FFI stuff is it's probably
going to be one of the faster ways to do
it and it allows you to write this API
of this wrapper that will hit a whole
bunch of different languages whereas the
C API C API stuff the only advantage you
really get there is the runtime that you
do you don't have the runtime dependency
okay so I've said that there are some
drawbacks to all of these I think that
there are some pretty significant
opportunities for improvement here so
this is my call to action for the FFI
approach one of the big problems is I
had to write all this crazy stuff but
you know you could write a procedural
macro that generates this from inputs
just like the PI o 3 case except not
Python specific I think that could work
and if you're ambitious and you want to
try that you could also if you're not
really big into the rust side of it I
think there's also a lot of improvements
that could be made on the Python side
right where this is probably a fairly
common pattern where you're going to
have to allocate and deallocate things
why not have a library that has wrappers
so you can just decorate your your
Python functions
with this thing and it will say oh I
understand that this is like a rust
vector and it's it's used in this
specific way and here's how I turn it
into a list and then there's PI o3 hi
this is a screenshot I took yesterday
and you can see the latest commit was 23
minutes ago so this is actually a very
actively developed project they're very
welcoming of contributions and you know
if you ping me my github is there I will
review your pull request for sure so
this is something it can use a lot of
improvement and it's rapidly improving
and so on both sides like the first
things you would have to take ownership
and create your own library and if that
appeals to you there's definitely
opportunities there and if you're really
just trying to get your feet wet this is
a much it'll be a very valuable thing to
do and it's much lower I guess burden on
you alright well that's my time so thank
you for coming to my talk
thank you very much Paul
we don't have time for questions in this
talk but I'm sure Paul we available to
chat after the talk
you